[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie we have new
immortal weapon confirm so let's break
it down if you're just finding my
channel for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
this - most of you are probably at least
a little bit familiar with Davos as
character from the comics probably the
best most recent Davos arc in the comics
is map fractions immortal weapons and
that's where we see him do a bunch of
different things so I'll do a quick
history on that because the TV show is
changing a little bit of that but he
gives you a good idea for what's going
on here they still use the comics as a
guide even though the plot isn't copy
paste you can kind of see how they're
moving through comic book arts towards
the capital cities of heaven in the
tournament of heaven like that's
probably gonna be Iron Fist Season 3 so
the big deal here is is that as of
season 1 or sometime in the first couple
of episodes Davos gains the Chi of
someone else or learns to harness his
own there are a couple different ways
that he gets that power in the comics
because he's been defeated by Iron Fist
a couple times but he's brought back to
life by cosmic forces or he's really
other capital cities of heaven to become
their immortal weapon so rewind to the
end of season 1 what we do know is that
joy Meechum is sort of the human villain
of season 2 she sort of Rises starts to
hate Danny R and then Davos approaches
her I can help you with your Danny Rand
problem maybe he told her a little bit
about his history with Danny she
probably doesn't care she wants the
company so that's why she wants rid of
Danny Rand but there are many onion
layers worth of reasons why Davos wants
Danny Rand dead one because he felt like
he should have been the Iron Fist of
Kunlun like they came up together they
trained together that's what all those
training scenes are of them fighting
with you see the Thunderer here that's
Davos his biological father who's in
charge of training everyone so Davos got
his ass beat in front of his dad Danny
Rand became the iron fist so he feels
like he's owed retribution for that
Davos was born in Kunlun it's part of
his lineage his heritage he views what
Danny did as coming to steal his
birthright so that's one reason but then
it got worse like he hated Danny even
more because as of the end of See's
one Kunlun had disappeared or seemingly
disappeared but since the hand has
effectively been wiped off the board as
the end of defenders I don't think that
they are responsible for what happened
to Conlon
I think it's either one of the rival
capital cities of heaven or it was a
tournament situation Danny wasn't there
to defend Conlon's honor during a
tournament another capital city of
heaven won so the celestial clock
shifted so Kunlun is still there but
because it's located in a different
plane of existence it has to be
connected to the mortal plane in order
to do that it has to be a certain
alignment with the celestial clock
that's formed by the seven capital
cities of heaven so we haven't quite got
to that on the TV shows yet like they're
still trying to be really real world I
think we're just building up towards
that and that'll be like a future season
in the comics the first way the Davos
gets the power of another iron fist is
by literally killing the previous
version of iron fist before Danny Rand
Orson Randall that might be where Davos
got his power from here or they could
have directly skipped that and he could
have become the mortal weapon of one of
the other capital cities of heaven
because the only reason for him to team
up with joy Meacham is is because she
has almost limitless assets and it just
takes a lot of money and a lot of
manpower to gain access to the capital
cities of heaven if you don't have
direct access so he doesn't care about
anything the joy is doing any of this
real world stuff he wants to get back to
Conlan but he needs to kill Danny Rand
and take his power in order to do that
so I know what kind of looks like he is
stealing qi from some of these people
here - I think he's just beating the
crap out of them on his way - Danny ran
remember during Luke Cage season two
Danny said that he's not using his
family's money anymore he's still
protected by that corporate structure so
there's still people around him that are
watching out for him besides the got ran
to purchase the building and a lot
underneath it so no harm done
it's not like I'm gonna pursue a
complaint is it
you're right though money is power but
what I'm really hoping is is that while
joy is the human villain I'm hoping
we're gonna get to meet one of the other
people from the other capital cities
that have been like if we're actually
going to meet crane mother because we
kind of thought that that's what they
were doing with Madame Gao but as they
explained that she was a member of the
hand even though she lived in Kunlun for
a time she might be connected to one of
the other capital cities of heaven but
unless they're pulling a really big fast
one on us she died at the end of
defenders and she really is just a
normal person and crane mother will be a
different character so remember how
during season one we all expected to see
Orson Randall we might actually get to
meet one of the earlier versions of iron
fist
they're very nebulous about the timeline
like the iron fist that Lee saw during
season one that lit both of his fists up
that could be the TV show's version of
Orson Randall or it could be someone
after him but that's sort of like iron
fist version of stick but also remember
that the chaste still exists it seemed
like they killed most of them during
defenders so there could be others out
there that can help Danny but for the
most part he's supposed to be on his own
and he's one of those characters that
doesn't know everything about his
heritage
that's where Orson Randall shows up in
the comics and becomes his obi-wan
Kenobi teaching him about the history of
the iron fists remember Davos wound up
killing Orson Randall in the comics so
we might get a version of that but we
haven't seen any evidence that Orson
Randall is gonna be a character on the
TV show so that's still speculation at
this point but it's all about finding
out what happened to Kunlun at the end
of season one getting back there and
then introducing the idea of the other
capital cities of heaven in the
tournament of heaven which I feel like
they'll probably leave for a future
season because if you look at the titles
for the episodes of iron fist season two
they're all titles of the comic but it's
mostly just Davos vs. iron fist like
it's basically just teasing an epic
match up between the two of them it
doesn't say anything about a giant
tournament of immortal weapons from the
other capital cities that tournament
only happens every 88 years so there's
the celestial clock that all the capital
cities of heaven exists and what happens
is is every 88 years all the cities will
converge and they'll form this special
secret city that they'll gain access to
inside that place
is where they fight the tournament and
whoever wins determines the order of the
celestial clock for the next 88 years so
even though they're determined to keep
these shows really stuck in the real
world I'm hoping that we get into a
little bit of that because that's where
the defenders characters get to go do
supernatural stuff that's like their
version of infinity war even though I
know everybody wanted to see them in the
actual infinity war there been a lot of
the actors that have said that they
don't think that they're actually gonna
do defenders season two so what they
might do if they want to do the big
tournament is it'll just have characters
from the defenders crossover like Luke
Cage goes to Kunlun remember they tease
that during Luke Cage season two between
me that dragon that you fought that was
metaphorical right wasn't actually real
come on one day I'm gonna take you to
come on the way you pay that off is by
having Iron Fist season 3 hopefully a
season 2 is much better than season 1 so
everybody wants a season 3
during that you do the tournament and he
takes Luke Cage to Kunlun with hopefully
Matt hopefully daredevil gets to go to
Kunlun at some point the martial arts
that stick taught him are the martial
arts that you learn in con lunge so
that's why he can fight just as good as
Danny Rand there's a whole bunch of Game
of Thrones and other stuff that drops so
I'll try to get those videos out as fast
as possible leave all your requests in
the comments below but congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big
video Marvel king please email me on the
back of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a new round in
this video all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video click here for that
Avengers for Marvel 10-year anniversary
promo and click here for all those
infinity war deleted scenes thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight